tom brady is not happy
and tom brady is not a guy to complain
he is not a guy to say get off my lawn
although maybe he's becoming one he
doesn't like
the rule change peter the one that you
predicted correctly would
pass easily and i didn't see a whole lot
of pushback
to the expanded jersey numbers from a
strategic standpoint until after the
rule was passed
here's tom brady social media it's dumb
it's going to make for a lot of bad
football
i guess it confuses quarterbacks when
they see a guy in the 20s is he a
defensive back is he a linebacker who's
blitzing who's the mic
seven is the mic that's going to be
weird when they're yelling it out the
line of scrimmage
peter i can't imagine when you consider
how much film you study in advance to
the game tom brady's ever going to be
confused
about who it is on the other side of the
line of scrimmage whatever jersey number
they're wearing
you know before this happened i had one
guy who works for a team shall we say
say to me that this is going to be a
debacle i said why
and he said this going to be a debacle
because everyone
in the nfl is used to studying
certain plays or certain players
at certain positions and now what's
going to happen
is you're going to see all these numbers
and you're going to see let's say you
know a linebacker
who's you know number seven let's say or
whatever it is and i think what you're
going to do
is you're going to assume that that guy
or let's say a linebacker who's number
22
you're going to assume oh yeah strong
safety and he's just playing down in the
box
and and i think that is why a lot of
traditional you know players
and uh you know scouts coaches and
everything
don't like this rule but mike there's a
very simple reason why this rule
happened
and there's a simpler reason why no one
in management or ownership or really you
know had any complaints about it
whatsoever
last year the kansas city chiefs had
three players on their team
who wore the number 30. and two of them
were on the team at the same time one of
them got injured in training camp but
was out for the year
but then during the season two guys were
wearing the number 30 and they would get
to sunday and they would have to decide
you know one of them was a running back
and one of them was a defensive back
and at that time brett veach just said
internally he said
we've got to do something about this we
just don't have enough
numbers you know and so we need
to spread out who can have these numbers
and mike the biggest
culprit is the fact that practice squads
are going to be somewhere between 14
and 16 this year after being 16 last
year
that is why you know that combined with
the fact that some teams have
11 or 12 retired numbers that's really
the reason why this had to happen
and the fact that bretveech and other
administrative types
saw that problem and for example in
kansas city
andy reid the head coach of the chiefs
didn't grab brett veach by the caller
and say uh listen you know he starts
every answer well listen listen beech
this is going to screw things up for us
that's not a very good andy reed
impersonation but they you get with the
point
but the but the point the point is this
where were the head coaches right when
there's a rule
change that is rocketing through
and guys like peter king are reporting
in football morning in america it's
going to
pass easily they're on notice where were
they
before wednesday shouting from the
rooftops this is going to be a debacle
unless it's andy reid john harbaugh bill
belichick
bruce erians any of the big name coaches
in the nfl
saying whoa whoa you guys want some
bad football you go ahead and pass that
rule
those voices were silent before the rule
was voted on and passed easily and the
fact that brady didn't say a word about
until after it passed peter
look i understand he's probably above
the falter all of
nfl news and information but if it's
going to affect you i'd like to think
greatest player in league history is
paying some attention why didn't he say
something before wednesday peter
well that's a good question maybe he
doesn't read football in america as
quite as attentive
but hey look i don't think you ask
why did andy reid not make a big deal of
this
i'm just telling you this right now mike
brett veach might be upset about
something and
and maybe a few other people the
equipment manager
of the chiefs might be upset about
something but i can just tell you this
if andy reid didn't like this rule the
kansas city chiefs would not have
proposed it
so i can tell you that andy reid is not
upset about this rule
he just is going to shrug his shoulders
and look mike
you know i think sometimes
there is a little issue of the day
let's say which this one is going to be
some quarterbacks clearly are not going
to like it
because it's going to make film study a
little bit harder
but i also think that if you really ask
yourself this question and again
i'm not in the film room so i'm not with
those guys as they say oh this is a
terrible this is going to be make this
harder that harder
you know i i guess that i am
like what one of the club executives
told me over the weekend when we talked
about it
you know basically his whole attitude
was hey listen
we gotta loosen up a little bit you know
it's just not that big a deal
and i kind of agree with him hey mike
you know what is really gonna be fun
though
here's what i hear robert woods and
jalen ramsey of the rams
each want to wear number two now ramsay
you know
in in college was number eight at
florida state
woods though was number two in college
and so i think he's gonna call dibs on
number two
because he's uh he's got more
he's more of a veteran player and he's
also got seniority
on the rams so unless
jalen ramsey parts with some of his uh
some of his contractual gains i think
you'll probably see
woods with number two and who knows what
you'll see
uh jalen ramsey with we had robert woods
live last thursday on the program we
talked about that very issue this land
rush that will ensue in locker rooms
throughout the nfl
for not just the single digits but the
other numbers that have been
expanded for use by linebackers
linebackers can go in the teens in the
20s and the 30s now
you can have running backs in the 80s ty
montgomery had been in the 80s because
he started as a receiver there's a lot
more flexibility
than just expanded single digits so
you're going to have some jostling like
that let me tell you this peter
here's where players need to be aware
and there was a report last night from
the saint paul pioneer press the dalvin
cook thinking about moving from 33 to 4
but he's looking into how much it will
cost him
by virtue of all of the unsold
dalvin cook jerseys now i've been
working on this and i actually do some
work for a change every once in a while
i try to
do some original reporting it's not very
often it gives me a headache so i don't
try to do it very much but
i'm aware of a player who has expressed
an interest
in changing his number to a single digit
and he's been informed by his team
that to do so will cost him
170 000
dollars because he has to buy the
fanatics
inventory peter not at cost
he's got to buy it at retail can you
believe that i mean there's something
inherently unfair about it
but that's the kind of fight that we're
gonna see and you're gonna have some
guys
and the more popular players who are
more likely to have a stockpile of
jerseys with their numbers already on
them
those are the guys who are going to be
at a more
difficult spot when they're trying to
trying to squat on a single digit number
or some other number because
the price for them is more likely going
to be higher than it would be for
somebody that
that nobody buys their jersey as it is
so there's no inventory that's out there
that would have to be purchased
you gotta figure i was just gonna say
that you know let's say you're dalvin
cook and you
want to make that uh you know for
whatever reason
vanity preference what whatever the
reason would be
and let's just say that you're a fairly
popular player like i would assume that
dalvin cook's jersey
in minneapolis is going to be
one of the most popular jerseys of any
athlete in the twin cities
and so you gotta you've got to factor
that in mike and the one other
thing that i believe you're going to see
happen
is you are going to see a lot of the
lesser lights who are not going to have
a bigger cost you're going to see them
be more anxious to change jersey numbers
because
if they don't have much to buy back
what's the big deal they'll just change
jersey numbers who knows maybe it won't
some players it probably won't cost them
anything
and peter the conversation that came up
in the context of the jj watts signing
with arizona and the unretirement of 99
that's going to be an issue potentially
eventually and i've still got on my list
of things to write about all the single
digit numbers that are retired
will there be a little push and pull
will there be
jersey is retired until it isn't with
some of these other teams
as guys start to hover around jerseys
that previously weren't available to
them
i think the other part of this is mike i
i mean
you know because the nfl has become a 24
7 365 league this is just
one of those other things i never even
thought of this when i first wrote about
it a couple of weeks ago
i it just didn't occur to me that people
were really going to think it's a big
deal
but i would say of everything i've
written about this off
season uh i would say
the biggest reaction i got on twitter
is when i wrote about these numbers
and and different websites would pick it
up like
i think bleacher reporter somebody
picked it up
and i i just i had to not look at
twitter for like 24 hours
it was a just a a vast expanse
of opining about numbers and
different team or different fans wanted
their guy to wear a certain number and
all that stuff and
i just never figured that this was gonna
be a big deal but
hey i'm 63 years old i guess it's not a
big deal to me but
to somebody who's a lot younger it must
be for how many years you've been
watching
the nfl how long now
you know 50 55.
there was one change like this in the
past 50 years and it was when they
allowed the receivers to wear numbers in
the teens back in 2003
and i didn't like that at the time i was
like oh i don't wait a minute what are
we doing here
and it's funny because my reaction now
is what the hell let's do it because i
think i've assumed at some level it's
coming ever since mike ornstein tried
aggressively to get the nfl to change
the rule for reggie bush
so he could wear five back in 2006 i
just assumed at some point the nfl would
do it
but i think the reaction is predictable
and obvious because it changes the way
that we see the games and football is
such a visual
medium we are going to revolutionize
what it looks like at the nfl level it's
going to look like it does at the
college level you're going to have this
swarm of numbers at positions we've
never seen before
it is going to take some adjusting and
it does create
this cottage industry of which player is
going to try to get which number and it
really is amazing to me
the tom brady of all the hills he could
choose to die on
and he never does when has he ever
complained about a rule except you know
rule about how much air is allowed to be
in the bladder of the football other
than that
when's he ever complained about a rule
when's he ever and of all the rules
and between the timing and the fact that
he's coming off like old man get off my
lawn at the age of 43
you know once we scratch past that tb-12
surface maybe is clint eastwood
gran torino it's just odd to me hey that
this
is coming from him on this issue
this is crazy mike but i honestly when i
saw that tweet yesterday i honestly
thought
of clint eastwood and gran torino i i
i'm
serious i can't believe you just said
that but the reason i thought of it
a reason i thought of it is older guy
probably 20 years ago wouldn't have
cared about this
but now he really does care because he's
a little bit anal
in his old age and tom brady i'm sure is
exactly the same way
he likes things the way they were he
doesn't see any big reason why they
should change
and you know what i'm sure in brady's
mind if
there have to be duplicate numbers on
the practice squad
you know why is that me look at that
why is that it's always you because you
you yell at
clouds all the time i have yellow clouds
all the time
yeah you do but can i let me let me just
make one one other point
brady probably thinks if he sat in a
room
with brett veach he would say okay
give two guys on the practice squad 30
give an offensive and defensive lineman
on the practice squad
give them both 63 or whatever
and and you know so but don't
cloud the game on sunday
and i'm sure that's the way brady thinks
and the way the chiefs think
is we want everybody to have an
individual number
and the other thing too if there really
was some great strategic advantage to
having this
blur of dissimilar numbers for
a defense nick saban would have the
alabama defense and
in all sorts of funky numbers he'd be
using ampersands and exclamation points
his numbers if there was some sort of
advantage
to to this so i i i don't
that's what makes it even weirder number
one tom brady shooting his shot
on something like this and number two
him missing the mark so badly
it just is weird i i don't i'm not
complaining about it he's giving us
all the folder all we need to start the
show on a friday and we've got
two or three stories about it on pft and
i'll probably write another one or two
because people are interested people
like this because it is going to change
the way we see the game hi i'm mike
tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports